وصل الخبز اليومي إلى رغيفين
لكل شخص في مدينة
بهاموت على خط المواجهة في شرق أوكرانيا
، لا يوجد غاز هنا والمخابز لا
تعمل ، لذلك يتم نقل 10000 رغيف
هنا 10 ساعات كل يوم
تأتي الزنبق مع
حفيديها وتقول  تحاول
حمايتهم من أصوات الحرب
ونخبرهم أن هناك بعض اللاعبين يلعبون
بالدبابات ، وتقول كيف يمكنني الإضرار
بصحتهم العقلية ، ولا يجب أن تفعل
ذلك من المستحيل
أن يكون هدير
النار الأوكرانية الخارج متطوعًا يساعد في تسليمها.
الخبز الذي يعيش في باكموت غير وارد ،
لدي طفلان وأربعة
أحفاد ، أخبرتني أنني أحبهم
جميعًا أريد أن نعيش جميعًا هنا ، إنها
أرضنا كل شيء سيكون على ما يرام الله
يحمينا
الوظيفة هي التحقيق في كل ضربة في كل
مبنى متضرر  بالنسبة للغارة
الجوية
في باهاموت في
أي وقت
في الصباح
في المساء ،
لا نعرف
متى يكون هناك ضرر للناس
هناك ، يأخذنا إلى مدرسة ضربتها
الطائرات الحربية الروسية الأربعاء
الثاني  المارة كانوا مصابين بالفصول الدراسية
التي لم يتم احتجازها منذ شهور
ليست بعيدة ، فقد أصيب مجمع من
المستودعات الزراعية العمال
وهم ينقذون ما يمكن أن
تقصفه شظاياهم في سقف أحد
المستودعات التي تحتوي على مورد ثمين
لا نعرف دوافعه.
الروس لضربهم هذه المنشأة ،
تم ضربها ثلاث مرات مؤخرًا
صباح يوم الخميس ،
لكن لا يسع المرء إلا أن يتساءل عما إذا كانت كل هذه
الحبوب الأوكرانية
هي الهدف
udmilan كان طفلاها
يقيمان في مهجع تديره هذه المدينة منذ
مسيرة هربا من القصف الذي وقع بالقرب منها
بلدة تفكرت في المغادرة إلى جزء أكثر أمانًا
من البلاد ولكن ليس لديها ما يكفي من
المال وفي النهاية تسأل ما هي
النقطة التي يأتي بها الروس
إنها نفسها في كل مكان تقول عندما
يكونون الروس الذين تقصدهم ينتهون
هنا وسيذهبون إلى أبعد من ذلك
ومع ذلك ، لا يتم تذكير الآخرين بالقدرية
وهم ينتظرون الحافلة خارج المدينة
لماذا يجب أن يذهبوا إلى
أي مربي نحل في وقت السلم يغادر
مع قطته سيمون سيميونيتش
بن ويتمان CNN
أوكرانيا